i pledge to be a president
who seeks not to divide but unify
who doesn't see red states in blue
states only sees the united states
welcome back to cbs this morning if joe
biden
is committed to that pledge he has a lot
of work ahead of him americans are
fiercely split not only about policy
but on the basic decency of the other
side in a recent pew poll for example
only about one in five registered voters
said that they
share core american values with the
other party
and about nine in ten people basically
everybody worried that a victory
by the opposition would do lasting harm
to america
so one idea to ease this strain is to
give america what you would
any other struggling relationship a
little therapy
how are you feeling about the state of
the country i'm devastated
you are yeah i think our country is
more divided than ever oh it's terrible
it's terrible
after 244 years together as a nation
we seem to be growing apart are you
concerned about the polarization and
division in the country
absolutely yep of course i feel like
there's not a lot of compassion for us
as human beings for each other anymore
and just about everyone seems to agree
that the state of our union
is on the rocks yes yes definitely
definitely yes definitely like the
feeling where the husband comes home and
goes does his hobbies and doesn't talk
to the wife until they go to bed there
is a professor at the university of
minnesota who does
marriage counseling uh and who thinks
that america is a bit like a marriage
and the marriage is not going too well
we need therapy we do
yeah he does therapy as it happens he
is bill dougherty a family therapist and
co-founder of a non-profit called
braver angels which runs thousands of
workshops nationwide
once polarization takes root it's an
escalation
dedicated to repairing the bond between
liberals and conservatives
using the very same techniques that
dougherty has used
to help husbands and wives we are an
american family we sit at the same table
can imagine one big thanksgiving table
and
if we expel people from the table
because of their political views we will
lose
our ability to function as a country
doherty says americans first need to
decide that our democracy is worth
saving
and not everybody thinks so as one man
told us
we need to have a divorce a big threat
that i see growing right now
is the people who are saying that they
are morally compromised by having a
conversation with somebody who differs
from them
morally compromised because they are
condoning evil
this is a serious threat to a democracy
doherty says that addressing it requires
getting each side to take responsibility
for their role in the coral
but as we discovered over two days of
talking to voters across the political
spectrum
talking about the other side is a hard
habit to break
that was certainly true for biden
supporters our current president deny
science he is in denial about
a deadly pandemic the marriage counselor
professor would tell me
to tell you forget about the other side
forget about what they're doing
talk about the democrats how can they
help heal this divide they need to start
meeting halfway i just think they're so
self-involved with their own pardon me
for interrupting but the marriage
counselor professor would tell me to
tell you
forget about what the republicans are
okay i just find
the hypocrisy of what the republicans
are spewing okay marriage counseling
but trump supporters also struggled with
what doherty calls the humility question
is it hard to think about the ways you
and your party might be contributing
sure both sides are
i just i think the other side is just a
little too crazy for me
channeling the marriage counselor here
he would tell me to tell you
forget about the other side what about
you guys what can you do differently
i it's a tough one
still just about everyone we spoke to
was with a little push
willing to admit that their side is not
perfect
both liberals you think democrats share
some of the blame for the nastiness and
politics today oh yes
and i wish i could say oh no they have
nothing to do with it but they do
100 they do 100 and conservatives
i think the blame probably if you had to
be honest
would fall with the president his
criticism and his rhetoric
divided the country well i'm a little
concerned about the
president's refusal to concede embracing
conspiracy theories never helps
many were also willing to acknowledge
that our american marriage
requires a little give and take i think
that we should have health care for all
and i wouldn't take a compromise for
that
let's take that idea let's imagine the
marriage of americans democrats and
republicans
you're on one side and you're saying
health care for all
the other side's saying no way how do
you stay married
it's a good good point you bring up good
question i have to say because i
i wish i put some more thought into this
both parties talk about bringing people
together
but none of the policies or
conversations really
support that so i think if you're not
helping the situation then you are
hurting it that's very therapy-ish
it's insight like this that makes bill
doherty if not exactly confident
at least hopeful that america is on the
mend
i think people are starting to realize
we can't go on this way
i have hope that we're going to wake up
and see
divisiveness and polarization as our
enemy
not people on the other political side
oh i like that all right
i feel like the way i did it at a
therapy session i feel kind of exhausted
i know i know but you know some good
work was done yes divorce is not an
option and if you can't talk
there's really no alternative but
violence you don't want violence you
want to talk it out
it is so hard though tony when you feel
so that you feel you're right
i know so hard to see the other side and
they say that in counseling all the time
i know i know it but that's why it's
humility that's what's required yeah
but the question that you keep going
back yeah the right one which is what
what can you
do to make it better if everybody just
keeps looking at the other side and
accusing i remember get anywhere i
remember once in therapy
a counselor said to me gail do you want
peace or do you want to be right i go
i want both if i started a sentence i
remember once in therapy it'd be 8 45
i'd still be telling the story i know i
know
that was very good tony very i love when
you talk to people it's fascinating when
we hear ourselves talk about ourselves
and people take the time to talk it's
great